Ecco "Il pane quotidiano".
Una delle 15.000 onlus che distribuisce
circa 3.000 pasti al giorno,
insieme ad altre 15.000 onlus in Italia.
Lì di fronte,
ogni mattina troverete una lunga,
lunghissima fila di persone,
che sono alla ricerca di un pasto caldo.
"Il pane quotidiano" si occupa, insieme
ad altre migliaia di associazioni,
di 6.000.000 di italiani che vivono
in una condizione di povertà assoluta.
Ma ci siamo mai chiesti cosa significhi
vivere in una condizione
di povertà assoluta?
Vive in una condizione
di povertà assoluta
una persona che soffre
di una carenza di risorse tale
da mettere addirittura
a repentaglio la propria vita.
Parallelamente,
pensate che secondo uno studio
del Barilla Center
for Food and Nutrition,
il valore totale dello spreco alimentare,
solo in Italia,
ha ragiunto l'astronomica cifra
di 37 miliardi di euro.
Secondo la Coldiretti,
44 milioni di italiani
potrebbero essere
alimentati, nutriti,
attraverso le derrate alimentari
che quotidianamente sprechiamo.
Signori, stiamo parlando
di un'altra Italia
alimentata attraverso i nostri sprechi!
Perciò, spreco alimentare da una parte,
bisogno urgente dall'altra:
qui abbiamo il modo per connetterle.
Si chiama Breading App.
Breading è un'applicazione
che si pone come obiettivo
quello di limitare lo spreco alimentare
per redestinare,
alle migliaia di associazioni
che quotidianamente si occupano
di povertà, questi eccessi.
Breading è un'applicazione
il cui nome deriva da Bread, pane.
Un nome inglese.
Ed è un progetto nato qualche mese fa
tra Bergamo e Milano,
con la convinzione
che il digitale dovesse essere
una svolta concreta e positiva,
nella nostra società.
Vogliamo creare un'app che sia un ponte
tra negozianti e associazioni.
Vogliamo creare una rete
che trasformi questo piano virtuale,
questo piano di cellulari
che utilizziamo tutti i giorni,
in un piano di aiuti
concreti e quotidiani.
Ma come funziona davvero Breading?
Ecco Luca.
Luca è un panettiere che tutti i giorni
crea pane di qualità.
Vorrebbe aiutare, Luca,
il territorio in cui vive,
perché è un territorio
che da anni fa vivere bene lui.
Luca, tutti i giorni, alle 17:30
fa una stima del pane avanzato.
Ma quando Breading sarà operativa,
Luca il pane non lo butterà più.
Luca infatti sara iscritto a Breading,
prenderà il suo smartphone
e nella piattaforma inserità
il quantitativo di cibo avanzato.
Nel suo profilo, inoltre,
Luca avrà inserito
l'indirizzo del suo panificio,
e proprio per questo
dovrà semplicemente aspettare
che qualcuno passi a ritirarlo.
Mi chiederete:
Ornella, ma qualcuno chi?
Matteo!
Matteo è un giovane studente
che presta servizio
presso un'associazione,
un paio di volte la settimana.
Un'associazione che ha la sede
proprio vicina al panificio di Luca.
Luca in realtà non lo sa.
Matteo avrà iscritto anch'egli
l'associazione a Breading
e proprio per questo motivo
riceverà una notifica sul suo cellulare
contenente tutti i dettagli
degli avanzi del panificio di Luca.
Grazie alla geolocalizzazione,
Luca troverà Matteo alla sua porta,
e gli darà gli avanzi della giornata.
Matteo poi tornerà all'associazione
e presterà servizio alla mensa.
In questo modo, cosa sarà successo?
Che Luca avrà dato
tutto il prodotto della giornata,
e quindi avrà evitato gli sprechi,
mentre invece Matteo e la sua ONLUS
avranno in questo modo
risparmiato i soldi
per l'acquisto delle derrate alimentari,
che potranno così investire
in altri servizi da dare alla comunità.
Secondo lo SROI,
che è un concetto di valore
che permette di monetizzare
quelli che sono gli impatti dei progetti
che hanno un impatto ambientale,
sociale e ambientale,
noi sappiamo che Breading,
per la sola città di Milano
- per ogni singolo euro che andremo
ad investire all'interno della società,
porterà 18 euro
per la sola città di Milano.
Ad oggi non abbiamo
ancora l'applicazione,
stiamo arrivando a quello
che è il cuore del progetto, l'app.
E la nostra visione
è quella di renderla disponibile
su tutti i sistemi operativi,
parallelamente a una Web App
e a un sistema sms.
Nonostante l'app
non sia ancora operativa, però,
pensate che abbiamo già ricevuto
decine di richieste
da commercianti e associazioni,
dal piccolo paesino della valle d'Aosta
ma anche dalla grande
capitale romana.
E oggi siamo qua chiedere a voi,
a quelle che sono le vostre competenze,
a chi è bravo, in un aiuto.
Perché quello che vogliamo
è creare un'applicazione
che sia subito realizzabile
e che possa raggiungere
tutti quei sei milioni di persone
che vivono in una condizione
di povertà assoluta.
Per fare in modo che davvero non ci sia
bisogno di corsi, per capirla.
ma che tutti quanti possano capirla
senza bisogno di interfacce strane,
e che possiamo direttamente leggerla,
accendere il cellulare
e capirla, utilizzarla.
Quello che noi vogliamo fare
è trasformare quelli che erano
disegni di ipotesi, Matteo e Luca,
in volti in carne ed ossa.
E vogliamo fare in modo che questa app
trasformi numeri e speranze
in cibo, e pane,
trasportato dal calore umano.
In fondo, la tecnologia è solo un mezzo.
Sono le persone che la utilizzano,
a fare la differenza.
Grazie (Applausi).